now over to elliot page who's opening up
about his life since coming out as trans
and how this has helped him embrace his
truth and happiness
yeah joining seth meyers on late night
elliot looked back on coming out in
december of 2020 and the long journey
he's been on since including how his
character in the umbrella academy also
transitioned in the third season yeah i
love this so much and according to
elliott he was a major part in crafting
the development for his character which
was fully embraced by creator steve
blackman when we first talked about it
he
seemed really excited about
incorporating it into the show i feel
proud of it and uh excited for people to
see it were the people closest to you in
your real life
as supportive as the people on the show
yeah absolutely so
and
i feel really grateful for that i think
most people weren't surprised or
something i'd been you know talking
about with a lot of people in my life i
know that since you've come out as trans
you've had to re you've had to receive
uh
you know from the strangers from people
who don't know you as a person um some
pretty negative reactions what is what
is that journey for you been like
well you know it's
what i
want to focus on right now and is been
so extraordinary is the degree of joy
that i feel
the degree of presence that i feel
um i feel a way that i really
never
thought possible for uh
for a long long time so um
that's really what i'm focusing on and
embracing the most but of course
moments can be overwhelming um
i feel i feel like it's one of those
things where it's so unfortunate because
it's like we're all on the same team
here you know whether you're trans not
buying you know
gender non-conforming cis
we all have these expectations and these
sort of limits and constraints
i think it's made me better in so many
facets like
as a person and
i think as a friend and
you know relationships it's improved my
life drastically and
powerful
this is such an important moment too i
mean it's unfortunate that we have to
say it in that way but it is because you
know this is the first time that a show
has mirrored you know someone
transitioning in real life and we're
seeing that with this character and on a
show and not just any show this is one
of the most popular shows on netflix
right now so i i love this story so much
and i was just reading an article before
we came on and the fact that elliott
knew since the age of nine and and it
was interesting talking about the the
fame of juno
and how uh he was forced to wear a dress
put the makeup on hair especially during
the press right the press yeah
and i think i actually spoke with
elliott during tiff and just thinking
back to that moment and how he felt at
that moment and being pressured to do
that to great create the success of juno
so this is a very pivotal moment i i
hope i can use that word because it is a
historical moment and
it's great that it's happening yeah i
agree visario's saying elliot is very
sweet love him and nelson's like that's
cool yeah yeah that's cool i just think
it's so great too that you know
networks and and cable and
streamers and everyone is is moving in
this direction you know this is this is
what needs to happen and it can be done
such a creative and
supportive and loving way and and i love
that elliot feels that way about it and
and that everyone gets to see this so i
think it's fantastic it's interesting
you know watching what elliot was saying
you could see and this is just from my
perspective you could see a sort of like
pain in the eyes um
when
breaking this down and i can't imagine
what it would be like to go through the
day
and not feel like your authentic self
and then when you finally get to the
point where you feel authentic and
you're feeling liberated like i don't
care this is who i am
having to deal with people who don't
fully embrace you like that entire
experience is so
much and i can understand like
how difficult something like that would
be in another in another way but i just
i just i'm really just happy that this
story is being shared it's too bad that
it's still such a pivotal story in 2022
and that people are still
putting we're putting each other in
these boxes for what so that we feel
comfortable with this like thing that we
were taught and we don't even know if
it's true or not i don't know the whole
thing's a mess but anyway elliot
i'm like so inspiring incredibly
inspiring and you know what a torch to
to push through and have to hold it's a
it's every torch to hold so i just uh
yeah it's this is crazy is not doing
pressure i was just gonna say that and i
think that's why i think interviews so
important because and the one thing i
got from that was the fact that the
support of the close family
that he had was so important i think i i
hope that's a good message to send out
as we talk about this and people who are
watching right now who may be going
through the same process to know you
know family needs to be there so
hopefully it's a yeah very powerful yeah
absolutely